- On this episode we executed
the single best episode in
#AskGaryVee Show history.
The energy was just (groans).
Wait 'til you see how it ends.
(laughter)
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 229 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
Five for five, we did it.
We fought for it, it almost
got ruined with the last meeting
Garrett but I'm super pumped
to bang out a five ep--,
you know what?
When I said Garrett can you edit
it or whoever's editing it put a
little picture and run it in
real time when Garrett
was on episode--
- [Garrett] 26.
- [DRock] Wow.
- [India] That was one
of my first episodes.
- That was, no, no.
Really?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Wait a minute,
you and Garrett are
#AskGaryVee brother and sister.
- [India] I guess so.
- Amazing.
Super excited, it's
been a good week of shows.
Feel like fresh.
I think that's what happens
sometimes and I think, you know,
I love the word cadence.
I think when you're doing it a
lot you get into similar answers
and different things.
I think it's opened up.
I've been really impressed by
the tremendous answers,
just kidding.
I've been very happy though with
the quality of the show and
I hope you have as well and your
comments are absolutely oxygen
for so many of you that are
starting to watch now the
engagement in the comments
means a lot to me so thank you.
India, let's get into that show.
- First one from Ward.
- [Gary] Ward.
- Good morning, Gary.
This is Ward from
London with one question.
How much of the success of being
VaynerMedia do you think is down
to the brand GaryVee?
I think GaryVee might be the
best content marketing strategy
in history so how much of the
success of VaynerMedia
is down to that?
What if GaryVee the brand was
not there and what if GaryVee
was just running VaynerMedia
without producing any
GaryVee content out there?
So thank you.
- That's a good question.
Ward, I think he answer is both.
I think I have the luxury of
proof being in the pudding as a
22-year-old in a five year
period, I grew a business from
3 to 65 million
in the old world.
No capital, no real internet at
scale and so I'm proud that if
Gary Vaynerchuk CEO not
out in the ecosystem started
VaynerMedia seven years ago you
know it would be successful and
the truth is of course it would
be because really here's the
punchline Ward nobody in
corporate America, Pepsi
Campbells, the NHL, none of
our earliest clients
gave a shit about me.
You know what?
99% of my clients don't now.
Now, that would be naïve to not
understand that over the half
decade that I've been really
running the company, first two
years I was somewhat involved,
sales, mentorship with AJ and
I was involved but I'm full
pledge is what
I do for living now.
GaryVee is this is my
side hustle, right.
I think that
there's been benefits.
You know people walk in here.
I can think of a brand we just
won that there's the truth is
it's because of the
GaryVee stuff and so I think the
answer's both and I think
that's what's really cool.
I think one day people will
realize how much
I like to hedge.
I think of it as a hedge
like both matter they
help each other.
One's there if the
others not there.
It's kind of a little
bit of immigrant in me.
For somebody who's so on
the offense I've a lot of
conservativeness and
practicality that is the
foundation of what I do and
I think brings a lot of value to
a lot of people watching if
they can get through the layers.
And so, the answer is both.
It's a really smart question.
I think many people
have done both.
Plenty of people have done a lot
of business on the back of their
brand when they
entered it. Right?
Plenty of restaurants that
are named after famous,
millions of things.
Just clothing lines, unlimited
and many people are
just unknown assassins.
Met with a guy the other day
he's built two $400
million businesses.
Never heard of them in my
entire life nor have you.
You can't even find anything
about him and you know they have
the humility and the kind of
personality that allows that.
And so everything works,
not everything works for you.
Plenty of people built huge
agencies not being known,
just operators and there's been
agencies built on the
backbone of individuals.
P Diddy's agency is P Diddy
and great people that he hired
underneath but it
wouldn't have been there.
- [India] That makes sense.
- I'm really feeling strong.
I'm feeling great.
I feel like I'm really
hitting a stride here.
A pre-prime of my career.
- [India] Wow.
- I couldn't go with prime
because I got so much to go.
Pre-prime.
I like pre-prime.
- [Garrett] (inaudible).
- For you, you've
got a lot baby.
Alright. Sorry.
- [India] It's ok.
- Wyatt.
- Hey Gary, David and Wyatt here
from Demio and we wanted to ask
you a quick question.
- Was it challenging for you to
make the switch from selling to
consumers wine to selling in to
large businesses like
Toyota or Mountain Dew?
- And if so how did
you make the switch?
Thanks, Gary.
- It's been difficult because
I like selling to consumers a
little bit more and I did that
and I'm selling to
companies second.
So, like in a weird way even
at the height of my career
financially, power, brand I'm
doing something that is in the
short term, a decade, which is
long-term for every one of you
watching which is one of the
fundamental reasons I will win
more than most of you because
the level of patience I have and
humility to put in the work
is so much greater than you.
So in the short term, 10 years,
I've decided to do something
I don't like as much because it
builds the platform for them to
allow me to do something
that I love the most and
so this is the path I decided.
Builds the best framework for me
to go out and sell to consumers
again one day and I've enjoyed
and learned to enjoy and found
different nuances and challenges
in selling to B to B to big
companies but I definitely it's
probably the reason I've been so
hot on the wine stuff lately.
You know during my vacation when
I had a little downtime when
I was had some downtime when the
kids and family went to go get
the fruit stand and my brain
was getting crazy I wanted to do
some action I didn't go and like
hit up an executive to
expand B to B work.
I started looking at what Wine
Library was selling and try to
sell wine to people, right?
I still love the speed,
the speed in the
day-to-day interaction.
As a matter of fact, when things
are just thinking about for our
team is that I think
I want to start a little shop.
I think we need to sell stuff.
I don't like just GaryVee
t-shirts and stuff like that.
I actually mean like
because that's like whatever.
I mean like something.
I think we should brainstorm,
come up with
something and sell it.
- [DRock] That's be cool.
- Yeah, I think so too.
Cool.
- [India] Actually
this is not a video.
- Whoa.
(silence)
- Like a shop, like a shop.
The shop has no shot.
- [India] I knew you were
gonna say that so
I put in this question.
Just kidding.
So why is
VaynerSports different?
- Because AJ's starting the
foundation and I trust AJ.
What happens is you evolve
is, and this is very much why
VaynerMedia is important.
The level of understanding that
I have about the four people in
this room, DRock, India, Garrett
and Dunk varies given how long
they've been around but boy is
that the reason
I'm gonna be successful.
Where as in the past I tried to
do business with other people
and they've been amazing and by
the way for Kyle and Lindsay and
for all the other characters
I've jammed with
it's been my fault.
I've overpromised
and under-delivered.
Not happy for me, not excited
but what I learned was I don't
have the bandwidth.
I thought I could do everything.
I can't do everything and so
what you need to do is have
people that can do everything or
a lot and allow me to do magic
on top of it and look
Vaynermedia in
two years did 3 million.
I sold those clients but
AJ knew how to farm it.
I can do the hunting and then
when I decided to do everything,
3 to 100 happens in
a heartbeat, right?
So I think that that's what
I'm looking for and I'm trying
understand there's a lot of
people now I trust in here.
I can open a lot of businesses
but I want to know be smart
about this and things of
that nature and
so that's the difference.
- [India] Cool.
Think his name is Randy.
- That's down to self-awareness
and delegation but realizing
that you can't, when you're an
entrepreneur you're the most
optimistic person on Earth.
You can't deploy that optimism
against somebody else that's
driving and so what you need
is context and to be able to
delegate to a known
entity within your ecosystem.
Investing allows me to bet on
things that I don't control.
I don't need to do that with
my own businesses anymore.
Go ahead.
I can't hear this.
- [India] I think
he has his finger.
- Here we go.
- Hey Gary.
Randy Solovski here coming from
Pennsylvania and my question is
I want to interact with new
and more positive minded people
using the power of social media
and how would
I go about doing that?
Thank you so much,
I love your show.
Hope I can hear
what you have to say.
- This is great.
What was his name?
- [Dunk] Randy.
- Randy. I heard it.
Randy, we're gonna do an
experiment here and DRock by the
way I know Other Tyler.
Other Tyler!
Get in here.
There is a flaw.
Staphon doesn't edit anymore
but you what, get Staphon too!
Staphon!
By the way Staphon's
new haircut is legit.
- [Dunk] I love it.
- Staphon looks way better.
You do too.
Everybody's
upgrading their hair game.
You look good man.
I'm proud of you.
(laughter)
Even though you're not
editing anymore I'm making
this statement because you made
the flaw you've made the flaw
even and you love the
think you're perfect, DRock.
Other Tyler
you've made the flaw.
The amount of times of on this
show that I've said link that
shit up and then we
don't is unacceptable.
You're done with it so you can
go back to your thing though you
might get called back in.
If I'm asking for
something to be linked up,
it's gotta be linked up.
Alright?
So cool, that's it.
So like right now when
I link up what's his name again?
- [India] Randy.
- Randy, I'm
gonna link up Randy.
We're gonna link his Twitter
account in YouTube and Facebook
and I know some people
different and copy, I get it.
We'll also flash his handles.
We're gonna flash his handles
here at least his Twitter and
here's what's gonna happen.
Anybody who's been watching the
show for 100 to 200 episodes is
a positive and
like-minded person.
We got the
community for you, Randy.
Instead of giving
something philosophical
I'm gonna give you
something practical.
Vayner Nation if you think
you're an awesome person and you
have big ideas and you love
networking, I want you to reach
out to Randy and I don't
mean just tweet him
and be like "Hey."
I mean reach out to him give
your number, email like connect
Randy of the 500 people that are
gonna do it, 17 is gonna be a
real thing and
there you go, man.
17 like-minded,
positive people for you.
- [India] Yay!
- [Gary] You like that?
- Yay Randy!
(laughter)
- Let's go, let's go.
- [India] Last one.
- Last one.
- [India] Gus.
- Gus.
- GaryVee, thank you for
taking this question, man.
Your friend Gus Fernandez
from Orlando, Florida.
I appreciate it, big fan.
Here's my question.
The entrepreneurship Hall of
Fame just called, you're getting
inducted man in 2025 but they
need to know what
the plaque is going to read.
Let us know and which
hat are you gonna wear?
Are you gonna have the hat
that says CEO, NFL owner, what?
Let us know man.
You're the man.
Thanks.
- Gus it would be a
picture with a B on it.
My hat would have a B on it
and it would say Honey Emperor.
- [Garrett] For what?
- I want to build
a honey empire.
I want to be known as an
entrepreneur 20, 30, 40 years
from now that this was the guy
that came along and he built
$1 trillion empire on the way
he interacted with his people.
He created a true insular,
you know it's funny,
once in while when
people first kinda
meet me they're like
and for real in a
good way they're like,
"Are you building a cult?"
They're like razzing me a
little but there actually really
weirdly like I just
really love leadership.
I really love people winning.
I love winning and I just
generally believe that I can win
and you can win.
We all different ambitions and
different wants and if one wants
to go and then go do their
thing Mozel Tov, go do it.
Go win.
Shit, do you know how
interesting it would be for me
if somebody left here, if
Garrett left here and created
G-Squared Media it started
beating VaynerMedia.
I'd be like my God, kudos fuck
I want to kill him but like you
know like kudos.
Have nothing but
respect for the game.
Honey Empire.
I'm going to like this is what
I've always had difficulty with
how much Steve Jobs has
been put on a pedestal.
Cool, you invented awesome
shit but extracting value out of
people by making them cry and
pushing them to that place it's
just Star Wars shit.
You know the Force is slightly
better than the Dark Side.
Just slightly and
that I'm fascinated by.
And I want to build something,
what do you think this is about?
What do you think this is about?
It's about the woman I just met
in the lobby who works in this
new building that stopped
me and said, "I work here.
"I'm sorry to grab you.
"I found out about you.
"Everybody that's working here
"has been talking
about your videos.
"I watched it.
"I'm inspired,
I'm gonna do my own thing."
I can make money.
I can get fame and a lot,
I coulda did a TV show like,
I could have been on
Top Chef back in the wine day.
It was the number one
fuckin' show on TV.
I could have been famous then.
Way more famous than I am
right now eight years later.
Legacy, changing the game like
creating the framework for so
many of you out there to look up
to and aspire to to build your
honey empire so that good
can win 'cause that's good.
That's just good for all of us.
Honey?
- [India] Honey company
called Honey Empire.
- We're just gonna
sell honey, right?
If you own a honey farm let us
know because I'll JV and maybe
our first product
should be honey.
You might be right.
India, that was a good.
I think we're just gonna
sell honey on Shopify.
Just like honey.
Do you think we could do a
million in rev the first year?
I think we can.
Wait a minute.
You know what's really crazy?
If this was like a sitcom
I would love the
next scene to be
like literally like
it's a $28 million.
I feel like if there's, by the
way you want about a good piece
of content for Facebook or
whatever it is in four years
this clip with the interview
I do with FastCompany explaining
how we why and how we build
a $50 million honey company.
By the way,
I'm actually dead serious.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm in.
India, it's on you actually.
This is your parallel side
gig and you too, Dunk.
You love this kind of crap.
- [DRock] Porn shop.
- Yeah we didn't do the porn
shop 'cause Stunwin failed.
- [India] Yes.
I will not fail.
- Dunk, you're on it too.
I want to put two
people's pressure.
We're starting a honey company.
Question of the day if you had
to sell something and start a
company, a physical thing, what
kind of company would it be and
what would be the name?
Have the greatest weekend ever.
I'm taking my kids
garage sale-ing tomorrow.
The hustle start early.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.